-Our next guest is a talented
actress and comedian
you know from her work on
"Saturday Night Live"
and "Search Party."
She stars in
"Father of the Bride,"
which premieres June 16th
on HBO Max.
Let's take a look.
-Whatever she wants.
-I love that. That's beautiful.
But keep in mind that you never
want to put a bride
in a dress she can't afford.
So prices usually range
from about here to here.
So where do we land?
-How about there?
-Please welcome to the show
Chloe Fineman, everyone.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Welcome.
Thank you for being here, Chloe.
-Oh, thank you for having me.
-Congratulations on another
excellent season of "SNL."
-We did it.
-You did it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I feel like your tenure
at the show
has been over
a very difficult time.
And it's finally getting back to
a little bit of normalcy.
You guys had the actual --
the party after the finale.
-Yeah, we had an after party
in the ice-skating rink/
now it's a roller rink.
-It's a roller-Skating rink.
-The cool roller-skating rink.
-Yeah.
-And I'd never experienced that
before. It was wild.
-And it was always historically
where the party was.
My years, I felt like
every year, it rained.
That was not the problem
this year.
-No, it was about 120 degrees
outside.
-Did you feel like --
Was it a sweaty night?
-I was in, like,
a thin gold fabric
that kinds of holds smell,
which I didn't realize.
And it's the end of the year,
and you've bonded with
all these people, and you're
hugging everybody and saying
how proud you are, and I had
a big hug with Lorne, you know,
thanking him
for such a great year.
And then I walked over,
and my best friend was like,
"I say this as your friend.
You have never smelled worse."
[ Laughter ]
-Now, I will say, like,
a really good friend says it
before you hug your boss.
-Yeah, boss.
You know, there's celebs.
We won't name-drop.
Ronan Farrow -- I'm like,
"We should get a drink."
-And then you mentioned
your friend.
These were sort of
growing-up friends
that you brought to the party.
I mean, that is a really cool
party to bring --
-Yes, yeah, about the coolest
thing you can do.
-And did you take them to
the party after the party?
-Oh, yeah.
-Alright.
-So did you kind of, like,
do it up when you brought
your friends?
-Yes, I was like,
"Come to this after --"
Maya Rudolph is singing.
You know, they're dancing.
And then around 6:30, it starts
to kind of -- maybe it was 6:00
it, like, shuts down, and then
there's the after-after party.
And I get to be like,
"Guys, want to go hang at Kenan
Thompson's after-after?"
You know, and they were like,
"What is your life?
This is so cool."
You know, the show,
it's like this,
and on this night,
you get to celebrate.
So I was like,
"I got it. I got it."
And it was at
the Hard Rock Hotel.
Not to give anything away.
He doesn't live there.
That's just where the party was,
if you want to stalk.
So I was like, "I got the car,
I got the car."
So I got, like,
the black UberXL.
I was going to,
like, you know --
-Yeah, show it off. Yeah.
-Pimp it up.
And I get the address,
and we show up.
And then I accidentally Ubered
us to the Hard Rock T-shirt shop
at 6:30 in the morning in
the worst part of Times Square.
-Yeah.
-Like, Elmo was, like, hanging
off the -- You don't want to see
Elmo take the head off.
-Elmo's like,
"I only take it off now
'cause nobody comes here."
-Yeah, and I'm in my gold dress
and I look --
-This is your beautiful --
-Yeah, this is me.
-This is not someone that should
be seeing Elmo at 6:30.
-No. No, the photo looks
as drunk as I was.
-We should note, you're carrying
your shoes, the telltale sign
of someone who's up at 6:30
in the morning.
-Yes, and sometimes we have fun
paparazzo.
And this woman said that I
looked like an undone woman.
[ Laughter ]
She was like,
"This is, like, feminism.
Do you mind if I take a --"
Yeah.
-An undone woman sounds like --
I don't know.
Seems like something Cary Grant
would say to somebody.
-Yeah, yeah. It was very --
Yeah, my friend Grace Shaker
saw me just like, "Okay, take
my picture, I guess," you know.
-You did a wonderful sketch on
the show that I want to ask you
about called "The Understudy"
where you did
impressions of
your cast members.
-Mm-hmm.
-And, I mean,
it makes sense to me, yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you. Oh, yeah, yeah. Wow.
-So, I think, because you are
such a talented impressionist,
it does not surprise me that you
would have an ear for the people
you work with and spend the most
time with.
Were they all aware
that you had them?
-No.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
Did they all react the same?
-No.
[ Laughter ]
I was like -- So, Mike DiCenzo
and some writers --
-Yeah, great writers.
-They were like,
"We got this idea."
And I was, like, the most
nervous I've ever been
at a table read 'cause they
don't know I do this.
And I don't think Kate was
at that table read.
So the first time she saw me do
the impression was dressed
as her with the glasses and the
stripes and the wig, just, like,
"Do you like it?"
[ Laughter ]
-We had -- I mean, Hader -- Over
the years, we found out that,
like, Hader did have
one of everyone.
-Really?
-He didn't really show it off
until -- You would hear sort of
like through back channels,
like, "oh, my God, you got to
see Bill's you."
And I'm like, "Why hasn't he
shown me?"
-Right. 'Cause it's scary.
-It is scary.
-Yeah, Kate was like...
[as McKinnon] "How long have you
been sitting on this?"
[ Laughter ]
Oh!
[ Normal voice ] You know?
She kept calling me a witch.
-Being called a witch by
Kate McKinnon is really nice.
That's like a compliment,
I think.
-[ as McKinnon ]
"You little witch."
[ Laughter ]
-This is very awkward 'cause I
think sometimes there's that
thing where two talented
impressionists,
like yourself and me...
[ Laughter ]
...we do the same person,
and then it's like
who's going to do --
like, if there's a sketch, like,
who's going to do Anna Delvey?
'Cause, like, we both have
such good ones.
-Right, right.
-I feel like I should do mine
first.
-Please.
-Okay.
[ As Anna Delvey ]
Do you know who I am?
[ Laughter ]
The banks are closed in Europe.
I'll send you a wire transfer.
[ Normal voice ] Right?
-Okay. That's great.
-So let's hear yours. Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I mean, where were you
when we did the --
-I mean, I feel like this is --
Lorne is very shortsighted.
I know he's like a genius,
but the fact that he's, like --
-No one told me. I'm upset.
-He gave it to you because you
looked more like her.
-We should have put you
in a wig.
-I am her. You look like her.
But give us a little.
-[ As Anna Delvey ]
You look poor. You look poor.
Being on "Seth Meyers" is
very exclusive and very V.I.P.
-The fact that you made "poor" a
three-syllable word is really --
[ Laughter ]
'Cause she's like --
[ Cheers and applause ]
So, this is -- You're in
"Father of the Bride."
And you are -- this is sort of
the Marty Short --
the role that Marty Short
made famous.
-[ Normal voice ] Yeah, the
wedding planner. Yes, yes.
-And you've gotten to -- you did
a sketch with Marty Short.
He played Doug Emhoff.
-And I played Ella.
So we did meet.
That was pre-me playing
a wedding planner.
-Yes. And did you do wedding
planning research for this?
-You know, I --
It's Netflix, baby, you know?
It's like the Wikipedia
of the day.
I don't know. Is that so the
dumbest thing I've ever said?
-It's making me feel dumb
'cause I have no idea
what you're trying to say.
-You, like, Google, you know.
-Okay, gotcha.
-Or like wedding planner,
Wikipedia.
-So you didn't go follow
a bunch of wedding planners.
-No, I'm just like,
"Netflix has it."
-Oh, I see. So you just watched
a lot of wedding-planner films.
-There are so many shows, yeah,
and there's like, weird reality
television shows
about wedding planning.
-That's true. This day and age,
nobody has to go in deep cover
to learn.
-Totally. And then weirdly,
"The Home Edit" --
Anyone know "The Home Edit"?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Whoo-hoo, yes! Container store!
Yay!
They were so organized.
So I was like,
"That will kind of inform me."
And then they have assistants,
and I was like,
"Oh, that could be fun."
I'm just bragging now,
but I got my best friend to play
my assistant in the movie
because of "The Home Edit."
Inspiring.
[ Applause ]
-Yeah.
-And you had to, like, make up
for that whole Hard Rock fiasco.
-Right. Yeah.
-The last thing I want to ask
you about is,
your dad did improv comedy.
-Yeah.
-And still does? Does he still?
-Oh, yeah, baby.
-That's awesome.
-Uh-huh.
-By the way, I'm so worried.
Aren't you worried that our kids
are going to react that way
when people are like, "Your
dad's a comedian?" Like, "Ugh."
-Yeah, but, like, are you doing
prov three days a week?
-I'm not prov'ing anymore, no.
I prov'd back in the day.
I don't prov anymore.
I don't like watching it.
I don't like doing it.
-Okay.
-But did you ever --
When you were young,
did you ever get to improvise
with your dad?
-Yes, the story goes,
I was three years old.
-Three?
-Yeah, my mom was either
that or that, I don't remember.
And I would go to San Francisco
with my dad to improv,
and I would run on the stage
when the scenes were happening.
They take it very seriously
in San Francisco.
-Yeah.
-So he lifted me off.
I was crying, and my dad's like,
"Do you want a cookie?"
And then I just went, "I just
want to finish my scene."
[ Laughter ]
And here we are.
-You were like,
"The stage is my cookie!"
-My stage!
-"The stage is my cookie!"
-Yeah.
-Well, your instinct was right.
And it's very sweet that he gave
that space for you.
-It's very cool.
He's in an Audible podcast
I'm doing,
and he just got his S.A.G. card,
so watch out, world.
-Watch out, world.
Hey, thank you so much
for being here.
-Yeah, thank you.
-We really appreciate it.
Congrats on the season.
-Thank you for having me.
-Chloe Fineman, everybody.
"Father of the Bride" premieres
June 16th on HBO Max.
We'll be right back.